then we began having a look in this we
need a wonderful world of complex
numbers we started the e of them as the
name suggests just has numbers you can
add subtract multiply divide take square
roots all the usual things you can do
with numbers and that was great but we
learn very quickly that if we take these
numbers and mean that they they have two
dimensions right they have this real
Potamus imaginary part we can represent
them we can think of them differently
right and every time you look at
something from a new angle will
represent something in a new way you
gave you notice ideas right so for
example when we went into more odd form
right de Barras never told us there's
just this very easy relationship that
happens when you raise to how you just
add angles going round and round around
and so simpler to think about whereas if
I ask you to do this and all you were
equipped with it was a Cartesian
representation you would be sitting
there for a while even with binomial
theorem okay it's just so much more
elegant to do it or not cool so now
we're gonna look at yet another way my
complex I was just so versatile yet
another way of representing them which
again will give us all these extra order
this sort of insights that we'll get
okay sir complex numbers as vectors
let's get a definition of the board
what's a vector a vector okay
so again to key IDs right when we were
having a look at exercise why it was
just horizontal and vertical very good
when we talked about bog form we were
talking about modulus size distance from
the origin and an angle right this idea
where that's right down magnitude and
direction
is very very similar like it almost
feels like the same theme magnitude what
that corresponds to is it's very similar
to this idea of modulus right it's like
how big is this double modulus right
that's what it's related to a direction
clearly is what arguments that angles
are about okay but there is a subtle
difference and let me try and illustrate
it yeah still the complex yeah sorry old
habits die hard
okay so okay
now if we think about magnitude and
direction what we're really trying to
think about is rather than complex
numbers as a point like here it is not
so much geometrically the point but
geometrically the interval from one
point to another
okay it's all for one point to another
okay now we would usually call this Phi
is Ed one right if I will call it said
wait a second but if I wanted interval
right I need two points right it's like
a start and end okay so therefore I'm
not just gonna call this dead while I'm
gonna give it a name just like the names
we have for all the other points in the
past like a capital letter it's all
called this one that's my first one I'll
call that a the boom but what it
represents is my complex number in this
case I need two of them so we'll call
this one's n1 as is our convention sir
now have a look at this right before we
talk about this entry right here in this
case here if I were talking about
intervals intervals I could say Oh a
equals a oh right because they're the
same interval just looked at from two
different sides stop somewhere I end
somewhere but I end up with the same set
of points in between but if you think in
terms of direction direction and now I'm
writing vectors to indicate or go from
one to another
right these things are not the same
right starting from over going to a is
quite different in fact it's literally
the opposite of going from a to own okay
so to indicate that right
this is move like it does but I would
say oh and I would provide with an arrow
over the top to indicate vector
direction I'm going somewhere direction
really matters in this case is not equal
to a oh so this vector hanging off here
what's your mean important right is the
magnitudes the length of that that's
fine the direction is what I'm going to
add an arrow in now that indicates that
way don't show this just yet we're gonna
have a few more diagrams to draw on but
if I were to draw what if I were to draw
this same interval and an arrow like
this right ball like this oh do you see
that all three of these new vectors that
are drawn you know within reason sorry
you know you just keep me better than
that okay oh they're all the same
magnitude and more or less the same
direction
in fact these vectors are all the same
vector okay yeah
yeah okay now he's the whole point right
point if I'm thinking of back in terms
of more just arguing right
I literally by definition measuring from
here and then you go a distance and then
I measure from here you go up an angle
okay but a vector is not a bad modulus
and argument despite how closely related
those ideas are he said that well how
how long are you gonna how far you take
me away and which way you're taking
right and they don't care about where
you begin or well yeah because they
don't care about where you begin is not
a positive real axis that you're
measuring from and there's no origin
that you begin from they're all the same
vector now we do distinguish between
them and I'll introduce some language to
show you that but just this idea of
focusing on the actual interval as
opposed to focusing on the point that's
the key difference between thinking of
theirs as vectors or as points on point
okay
all right sir 92 Direction there's a Zen
one let's put up let's consider two on
here and again because I wanna have some
language that borrows my language of
points I'm gonna call it be very
unreadable okay now it B is up here then
OB would be this pet dog now barri what
you already know about complex numbers
and how you are given what that means
geometrically okay
for instance just as a first example we
don't want z1 plus z2 where would it be
on this diagram okay now without
parallelogram law in fact I'm even gonna
draw a parallelogram I hear what I'm
gonna do is now that effectively we
shouldn't get these guys up I can take
this Oh a vector okay and if I move it
up here like so
reposition it then I need these two
complex others together is the same as
stringing two
vectors together can I say that again
that's important
adding these two complex numbers
together is the same as 2 e 1 vector and
string it together with another one
right it's like step 1 step 2
all because addition is still
commutative right I could do step 2 and
then step one I'm still going to get
there okay so I've got this you point up
here which means haven't you vector
all right all right
okay so what I've got you blue that if
we call this point C the vector OC that
represents the vectors N 1 plus n 2
now I'll stay with my
so let's formalize some of this and I'm
going to give you some any language for
it I'm going to say Oh C and I'm gonna
put that line over the top to indicate
it's a vector it's called a direction
right because I see is from the origin
it's from the origin it gives me the
position over here so it's called the
position vector right it's the position
that not all said 1 plus C 2
in addition to that remember we said ah
you know you've got um this
parallelogram happening here right Oh a
C B so immediately like what is this
blue blue shape it's a diagonal of this
parallelogram right so I can say the
magnitude of this vector here right and
that vector represents is n1 plus said
two right so I can still use my my same
modulus notation because your friends
are the same number is right the same
values that is the way though it's the
length of this diagonal of the
parallelogram right